[Music]
foreign
one of the greatest UFC fighters ever
has a problem with an ex-girlfriend
we've all been there but not quite this
bad Israel and Sonia started kickboxing
around early 2000s made his professional
debut in 2010 and went on to have a
career that spans almost 15 years now
this is a girl who apparently he'd been
dating for since 2019 this lady was on
the scene for a few years as a
girlfriend not a wife not a baby mama
just a girlfriend and that's the beauty
of not putting a ring on it Lads they're
not entitled the jack [__] I strongly
recommend it until you're absolutely
[__] sure now despite the fact that
they do not have a child together we're
never married and I don't remember her
getting in the octagon and throwing all
those punches and kicks she thinks she
should get half of his money because
they're no longer together I'm sure she
supported him so much when she was
clapping from the sidelines not doing
anything but you know hard work doing
all those collapses in it we all know
that on occasion you know if people
separate and they have come together and
built a company together let's take for
example Amazon it's an easy example
where the husband and wife built the
company together from the foundations up
it wasn't about Talent that's all about
hard work and know-how in YouTube coming
together as a team and building a
company together I have no problem with
that scenario and what happened but this
is very different this is raw talent
this is like a great singer only the
singer can do what they can do the
fighter it's raw talent only them can
get in that octagon and do those magical
things yes she may have cut them a few
meals give them the odd back rub but
that I'm afraid does not equate to
anywhere near half of the effort it took
for him to achieve everything he did and
even the most wildly insane you know
feminist wouldn't in a million years be
able to wargue that she deserves half of
[__] now yes she might have dedicated a
few years of her life in the belief that
this might one day result in marriage it
didn't sometimes life sucks sometimes
you've got to be a [__] grown-up and
accept that you made a decision it
didn't pay off and that decision is all
on you you don't get it I'll cry because
you thought that this was going to
result in you becoming a
multi-millionaire one day because the
relationship didn't work out sometimes
that just happens grow the [__] up man
the level of entitlement in this story
blows my mind he's not your dad this man
worked his balls off for over a decade
before he even met you chasing this
dream this would have happened with or
without her and yet she thinks she can
actually ask for half this shows how
insane the world's gone now you know
it's bad enough that there are some
freeloading parasites out there that did
not lay a single brick in the company
that these men out there build and in
the event of a divorce they then get
half despite not having a [__] clue
how well all of the money even came
about most of the time just because they
were in a relationship with this guy at
least these women are actually in a
relationship the lawyers are even worse
they don't even suck the dick of the man
and they still get the [__] Feast on
the carcass of the poor bastard in the
event of a divorce but this this guy
didn't even say in a piece of paper this
was a fling a few years is nothing no
kids no nothing and she still feels like
she is entitled to half we're not even
safe anymore Lads just run and hide this
woman is Young she is quite capable of
providing for herself guarantee you
won't see Israel out of Sanya asking for
half of what she's with will you
equality oh it won't be needed in this
scenario will it and the funniest thing
is he dumped her he then went back in
for a title fight and won the title
fight without her well I never he
actually managed to win a title without
her probably because it doesn't make a
blind better [__] difference if she's
sucking his dick on the run-up to a
fight or not you're [__] freeloading
parasite this is one of the most
talented individuals we've ever seen in
MMA and she has the cheek to think she
should get half of it all of his
earnings when he's been getting the [__]
kicked out of him for years and getting
beaten up in that octagon and she didn't
take a single [__] punch Izzy has
posted some sort of uh Email exchange
between him and this guy girl back in
2001 so they have been clear of each
other for a while now she also said it's
not fun living in his shadow and taking
second priority because what he is doing
is so important after a while it just
makes me feel small you go after a
superstar in Israel and then complain
you're not equal to him this is that
classic mentality of let me go and find
a rich man and then complain when you're
not a power couple you're not a power
couple because you ain't bringing any
power to the couple okay Izzy then
responds I let you drift away into a
miserable existence because misery loves
company and you love being a victim
anyhow
I think you meant to say anywho I hope
you try and affect my businesses such as
Puma with your weak [__] threats you
never help me make money only ever cost
me money preach the irony of someone
Izzy spent a [__] fortune on trying
to then come back and take half claiming
she helped the naked this is just all
too common for powerful men it's
standard any men out there who are
making money you must be so [__]
careful because you are an opportunity
you are not a person and that goes for
your friends and your girlfriend think
about that and now you think you deserve
half my [__] what an entitled pump is
brat you are I spit on you
Izzy's Got the lyrics he's so [__]
funny I dare you to start your stupid
campaign your threats don't work anymore
this is the thing is this is a woman
who's been threatening him for a while
clearly how dare she these [__] gold
diggers get a [__] grip of yourself
have some shame didn't earn a [__]
penny of what this man has worked his
life for mixed with god-given Talent you
didn't contribute a [__] second of it
you are responsible for your emotions
you don't care about my life because
you've sold info about me she's
basically been selling it to the media
about stuff she knows about him I don't
even hate you I don't care about you
I've not been in love with you for a
while
that's the [__] that's what I'm talking
about is hit that with the nonchalance
mate let her know you nothing her no
hate no love you nothing her she don't
deserve hatred she's not worth hatred
people like this they feed off of energy
give them nothing in summary he's
writing this like an essay I'm glad this
all happened I wouldn't change a [__]
thing I'm glad I finally have someone
who can stand next to me and not feel
like my shine takes away from this
confident in their own like
Dom he is psychoanalyzing her right now
and this is so true by the way
ironically if she really was worth half
he'd have put a ring on it and he would
have known to do that had she have been
truly supportive not jealous of who he
was and just there to play her position
you ever heard of LeBron James right
LeBron James's wife did a very rare
interview and they asked her why do you
never want to be in the Limelight
because we've all seen people like
Rebecca vardy like Jamie vardy was
necessarily the biggest star in the
Premier League his wife couldn't stay
out of the Limelight LeBron James the
one of the biggest stars in sports
history his wife wants nothing to do
with the Limelight she just wants to
play her position and support her man
and be grateful and be there for him
that's a real woman we need to call this
[__] out I don't want anyone saying I'm
being misogynist here I'm against
parasites people who do nothing and
expect everything we all need to be
calling the show men and women because
it's [__] disgraceful behavior and it
gives women in general a bad name so he
said he ends it with is the last time
you're [__] here for me my lawyers
will be in touch and then with the
painting nails emoji that is the most
easy way of ending it so we will
continue to follow this case as it
develops because I think we're getting
an extremely dangerous territory here
and hopefully there's a little bit of
Common Sense from the court system in
New Zealand let me know what you think
about this in the comments below clearly
I think it's a [__] disgrace don't
forget to hit that like button stay
subscribed to the true Geordie YouTube
channel and I'll see us on the next one